Chris Brockman I love action somebody
needs a new pair of shoes Oh baby okay
that beard that beer your newborn
correct taste what cage is growing like
a weed all right the Belmont Stakes the
normally final leg of the Triple Crown
Oman stank's that that that that event
you set that into a microphone five NFL
Draft ago I think Chris and it's lived
it's lived in infamy forever
the Belmont Stakes it's the stakes on
NBC at 2:45 p.m. Eastern Time a whole
host of a cast of thousands Mike Tirico
and our friend who's back here on the
Rich Eisen show petiole Chuck
how are you and I heard you say baby
baby needs a new pair of shoes yes sir
I'm on the verge of being coming a
grandfather for the first time in a week
my older son Eddie and my
daughter-in-law Erika a couple of weeks
away from for bringing a new fall into
this world and we're looking very
excited and hard to believe that my
oldest son turned 31 yesterday and the
quick story if I could rich Eddie back
in the day and my hockey playing days I
was a member of the New York Rangers
back in 1994 remember we won the family
cup and read that in the celebration our
family Cup parade happened to be on June
the 17th of 1994 and all the families
assembled at Madison Square Garden to
get on the buses to take us to the
floats to go down in Manhattan Wall
Street in the canyon of Champions or
what have you so all the families were
there and at that time I had two very
young children my oldest son Eddie who
happened if that happened to be his
birthday was June 17th of 1994 but he
was born in 89 so these five years old
obviously my youngest son Tommy so we're
on the float and it's about 90 degrees
out I got my sweater on and you know
it's who got my shorts on in flip-flops
and it's like a thousand degrees
you got three million people out there
and celebrating the Rangers first cup in
54 years and I don't know maybe about a
mile into the trip
rich my my son Eddie my oldest son of
his birthday was that day yes tugs on my
shorts and kind of you know weighs me
down because he's
little fella you know when I leaned down
and he says dad I go yeah Eddie what's
up because thanks for inviting all these
people to my birthday party and I was
like you know what the rest of your day
the rest of your life buddy's gonna be a
letdown because I don't think they'd let
sue million people in the chuck-e-cheese
here
there's no Canyon of Heroes and
chuck-e-cheese I don't think exactly so
you know we we we actually spent some
time together yesterday and just kind of
reminisce I'm like where in the hell is
26 years gone so and and he's gonna be a
dad here in a couple of weeks I'm gonna
be a grandfather so yeah so really cool
so I guess since we're we are talking
about the sport of horse racing here if
you're a grand child is about to be
sired do you get a stud fee oh I know
it's probably costed me about two
million dollars as we say in the lingo
around the OL check house oh I don't I
don't I don't think I'm getting that
smell back I don't think but the joy
that is that is arriving soon can't wait
based on the conversation we had with
the Hank Oberg yesterday on our show
he's been our resident you know the
hammer has been one of our resident
handicapper or go to guy for so many
years and now you've joined us as well
as last couple of years on this subject
anybody looking to get rich on on bail
on the Belmont Stakes might have to wait
for the next leg right yeah I mean I
guess you could always look at it rich
and again being a horse player my whole
life and you look at it go okay well
kids a lot of the eight horses you know
the Kentucky Derby was run tomorrow he
would be the favorite and he's probably
the best three year old when he is on
his best and right now he is doing well
in New York bred you know running to
Belmont and we know the world we're
living in again let's put it all in
perspective we know what the real world
is this horse racing rules in another
world and it's entertainment it you know
we're gonna be working on NBC on on
Saturday I'll be working from home which
I'm looking forward to that and
handicapping hopefully making some
people some money and
a little bit of entertainment but look
it there's a log six to five morning
line meaning if you bet five you win six
I don't think you're going to get six to
five I think you probably didn't get
more like three to five meaning if you
bet five you win three so you put eight
bucks in your pocket in a matter of
about a minute and 48 seconds which I
think that people over at Wall Street
would probably take that every day of
the week if you can turn
5 into 8 for every minute and 48 seconds
you're working but how do you turn a
three to five shot rich into eight or
nine to one and that's my goal as a
handicapper and most handicappers is how
can you do that well you can do that by
exact is getting the exact order the top
two finishers or a trifecta getting the
top three finishers and so there's value
there if you don't like to is the law
you're gonna get paid but he certainly
looks like the horse to beat all right
any Olczyk you now have the floor on how
do you turn that into eight two one nine
two one you mean you've got the floor
well you know it's funny rich you just
mentioned eight to nine to one and the
two horses that I'm actually gonna build
all of my tickets around are the eight
nine horses the kids allows the eight
horses I'm gonna be the favorite huh and
I'm also going to use the nine horse dr.
post who is trained by Todd Fletcher who
is won the Belmont it seems like a
million times and one of the top
conditioners we have in our sport and
the horse is owned by Kenny Biola who
happens to own the Florida panther so a
little hockey guy in there ice Benny is
owned some really good horses he won the
Kentucky Derby a couple of years ago
with always dreaming anyone the Breeders
Cup Classic last year with vino rosso so
he's he knows his way around the bar and
he's got some good horse and this is
this is a really talented horse who's
coming into his own and again rich with
the pandemic and horse racing and all of
our lives being put on hold for a period
of time no difference in horse racing
this horse would not have made the
Triple Crown in a normal year just
because he did not mature enough or
quickly enough to get him to the races
in his three-year-old year so I'm gonna
be playing all of my tickets around the
eight nine nine eight and hopefully
turning that you know three to five shot
and says the law into eight or nine to
one so I would advise anybody that's
looking to play and get their feet wet
to make sure that they use the 9dr post
so now is is mandated asked us since you
say the the owners
the owner of the the Florida Panthers is
po is the post and dr. post a hockey
term hit the poster no I think no this
is more on a personal level for for
Vinny and the Saint Elias tables and it
is a hockey so yeah no no no no the
posters you know for goaltender's the
only the only people that love the
goalposts are the goalie no tie to
hockey as far as I know with dr. pols
for if anybody didn't know event Bambi's
Brooke was part of the ownership I
didn't you know yeah I went and I'm a
ranger guy and I went van B's Brooke
with Florida see I'm trying to connect
some dots here you know okay so who else
which which else what other horses other
than eight nine much you might you
consider here you know I think you got a
look at I think you got a look at the
two horse Soleil Volante horse that now
is I mean this is new this is old school
racing here this horse ran only ten days
ago which twenty-five and thirty-five
years ago that seems to be pretty normal
where horses ran yes thoroughbreds ran
if they were ready
ten days 15 days after a race now this
is the horse that will probably be
coming from a good distance out of it
rich but the source is doing very well
I don't think Patrick being called the
trainer would be would be sending this
horse in this situation the horse
finished second in the Tampa Bay Derby
to King Guillermo who happens to be
owned by Victor Martinez longtime
major-league all-star and player for a
long time he owns that horse king
Guillermo who might be right now
rich Victor he might have the second it
probably has a third best horse
three-year-old right now in training
ready for the Kentucky Derby so an
interesting storyline for your viewers
and listeners out there but I would say
you have to use the two horses well the
one horse tappet the winds got a lot of
speed but I think there's some other
speed in here that might put a little
bit of pressure so I'm gonna build and
like I said I'm gonna
but majority of my tickets are on the
eight nine no but I think you certainly
have to use the two horse soleil Volante
maybe as a horse underneath okay alright
any so did you take that down Chris you
take that down you're all over we're all
over okay alright our buddy Hank
Goldberg likes pneumatic and he likes me
what is it honored modernist okay well
look after after after hammer and hit
and in you're truly we've got it covered
I mean we see Scott we've got half the
field so what does that tell you okay go
ahead but the other pot no I know no
don't say that you know but you brought
it just like hammer did yesterday where
you not only give us your thoughts and
maybe can make some people some money he
brought some another wonderful story
yours is uplifting in the fact of your
beautiful son who's now going to give
you a grandchild thought that the entire
parade for the Rangers was for him and
his birthday that's a wonderful lovely
beautiful story just the on the opposite
side hank goldberg recounted the time
that Jimmy the Greek slapped brent
musburger across the face so that that's
on the other end of things okay but you
both brought it is what i'm saying and
we appreciate it full circle we got it
all we got it all covered under Rich
Eisen just glad to be a very small piece
of eddie i love when your on so thanks
for the call we'll have you on again
real soon be well you be well to a teal
chick joining us here
eight nine exact exact at box eight nine
he likes it yeah throw the two in there
if you want to exact a box something
other than tis the law you want a
trifecta maybe go for it bottom line is
tuning to the Belmont Stakes at 2:45
Eastern on Saturday Mike Tirico and cast
of thousands let's go hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here